we challenge GM Daniel naruditsky and FM
James Canty to our new variant spell
chess but we didn't tell them anything
about the variant see who figures out
how the Spells work first and wins in
our time control challenge
the way I understand it there are two
spells you can freeze a three by three
area of the board and then you can Mark
a piece
that you can use to to jump
um
so we're going to start with the
Sicilian here
I'm gonna play pretty much normal moves
until I figure out exactly what I want
to freeze
I don't see a reason to jump over any
pieces just yet
okay I'm gonna freeze James from
okay wait where's the phrase this is the
phrase
oh this is my freeze nope that's okay I
meant to freeze one to the right of that
but that's okay at least now he won't be
able to move his Knight okay
um
just press it on the bottom five and now
I mean tonight I think I'm gonna go D5
counter attacking the bishop
saying aggressively
the thing is he could freeze my pawn and
he could have taken my knight okay so
let's move the Knight back now I'm
threatening to take his Pawn because I
could freeze his Knight
and then potentially take the pawn but
I'm out of the freeze so I guess
oh and he froze my uh he froze my Pawn
that's very smart okay I think that's
how it works
um
okay so that means I lost a piece here
I see I see how this works
so once this unfreezes I might have to
take I'm gonna have to try to take his
Bishop
then he would just take it all right so
this is like I don't know
G4
[Music]
okay
I guess I'll take it
and my freeze will re-enable now okay so
he's taken there
now I'm down a piece
shot through this piece
I understand
a jump I still need to figure out
maybe it's only other piece
can this piece jump
that is the tricky one it's the jumping
thing so I'm down a minor piece
wait why did no oh James wants to jump
over into attack G7 so I'm gonna Castle
can I jump through this
he was attacking my Pawn on G7 because
the queen could have jumped over to take
my pie with this jump piece
I have both my freeze and my drums
okay let's go Rook C8 now I'm gonna try
to jump over the Knight
and take that pawn on C2
okay James is setting up Bishop H6 oh
but then
can you freeze again okay so I think I
can take C3 and freeze
[Music]
yes let's freeze this area
take the night
because now he won't be able to take my
Rook
oh of course he probably will play
Bishop H6 and then I'll have to play G6
okay but now he can set a jump on G6 and
play Queen G7 Checkmate I'm pretty sure
foreign
so I'm in trouble
[Music]
I think if James figures it out he mates
me
yeah this is why I'm not good at
variants
I'm gonna I'm gonna chess
um
okay he missed it he missed it I think
he oh and he froze me so that's annoying
Okay jump now let's go Rook C4 Jesus
nice but it's jumping is so hard I mean
he can still Checkmate me but there's
nothing I can do about it yeah that's
what if I put it on his piece I'm just
curious to know do I bounce off of it or
something
what does this thing do
oh wait okay he gave up his Queen for
some reason
yeah what is he preparing to do yeah
it doesn't do anything I'm not sure what
that was about I don't understand the
jump thing I'm not sure what that was
about to figure out for sure now he's
giving me a queen it is I think maybe he
thought or something unbelievable
um
okay D1
let's figure that out okay let's go
Bishop C6 now I have my freeze and my
jump
so I'm threatening to take the Knight
and freeze him he's in trouble now I
think because if he moves his Knight
then I could freeze
wait what do I want to freeze I want to
freeze
can I move into the freezing area
however other pieces can move into and
through that area you can also capture
Frozen pieces yes
so we can do that
okay so now I want to bring my queen up
to G5
I don't know if I can jump through a
piece to capture a king though
okay Queen G5 yeah looks like I've got a
nice position here once the bishop
unfreezes I'll be able to take the Rook
maybe I should have played Bishop F3 and
then jumped over oh I could have played
Bishop F3 and jumped over the Knight and
made of the king
that's true
but I still think I'm winning
okay what if I freeze
some things I don't understand this area
and then take his Knight lost my queen
and lost the game no I did not want me
to do that oh
okay I guess I'll just take the pawn
then
what is this yeah I could have made it
him by moving my Bishop back and then
freezing the Knight and got going Queen
G2
how does this work Rick nope
Knight no
man I wish I could jump through this pun
okay let's go H5
Queen F4
now I can maybe jump through the pawn
and take the king that's what I don't
quite understand
can I do that
okay so King H7 otherwise you would have
taken and Frozen me
okay now I'm planning to start taking
all his Pawns
hmm
yeah so he's Frozen like oh he's Frozen
my queen oh
that's not good
foreign
now I'm gonna have to wait why don't I
have my freeze yet oh five moves oh
no
ah no no no no no he's gonna take my
queen
no
and now my queen unfreezes okay but
that's not the end of the Worlds
okay I'm gonna have to take his Rook now
B4 now try to make a passer
[Music]
I don't know why I don't have my freeze
yet
I guess we're done like there's no more
freezes
we're just playing chess okay if we're
playing chess then I lose
yeah I don't know why why I don't have
any more spells
that's kind of lame but
[Music]
okay in that case I'm gonna resign
James
we're starting a new game with James I'm
gonna go E4
[Music]
and he's gonna go E5 well I'm gonna
start with a pretty normal opening
let's go Bishop C4 play so this is where
it gets a little strange because he can
take and free stuff
so we go Knight F6 he takes and freezes
okay so I actually could take his Knight
and jump over the one page I don't even
know
but that doesn't seem to be a very good
use of the of the jump
I could take F7 and freeze him
okay let's go Knight G5 and if he goes
D5 I'm gonna jump over the pawn and take
the bishop or take the pawn to check
oh actually this is uh
pretty good move I played there I think
we're playing the fried liver and it
seems to be a good opening in this game
freeze this area
and play D5
yeah oh he froze okay so that makes
sense
that makes sense okay Bishop B5 maybe
the thing is you have to time it right
the timing has I guess I can't jump and
take over
oh wait I can't move the bishop okay
it's a frozen Bishop okay I guess we
Castle the freeze is like what freezes
two moves okay so yeah just like two
moves so let's go H6 can you take and
freeze bro that's so crazy he could you
got a time and freeze the whole King
area
H6 take freeze or maybe I can just
freeze the king but not freeze the
Knight oh that would have been very
smart I'm just gonna move the kind of
strange yeah I could have taken F7 and
then maybe Frozen the king so it
couldn't take my knight but then I'd
take one of these two pieces
yeah that makes sense
okay I'm gonna do that now
I'm going to go freeze
so he Forks this is like not even real
openings don't even matter no
yeah he freezes the area
yeah now he can't move his King but I
can take his Queen oh I win the queen
I think I win the queen because I can
move into the Frozen area oh that was a
sick move
you take my Bishop I take his Queen who
cares oh yeah you can take in that area
yeah not that that's such a big deal in
this game but still okay so now we're
unfrozen
all right can I jump over anything no
definitely a good opening in this
in this game here
two jumps okay I don't do anything yeah
this is Castle this is the castle
okay I'll take the pun don't see why not
okay let's go Bishop G5 now I want to
jump over the next oh but I blended my
Bishop you can just jump over and take
oh my gosh let's see if James realizes
it
he can jump over his own Knight and take
my Bishop I forgot that it goes both
ways
six
freeze
this is freeze available it's after the
next one
I just take
[Music]
phrases delirium tank uh living care
okay he didn't see it
okay so we're gonna put a jump on the
Knight and take his Bishop
he didn't notice it whoa now I can also
take the jumps the night as well or The
Rook okay I'll just take the route like
this one okay I think I'm in good shape
here I think we can take the Rook
takes
a bunch of pieces here okay what if I
play Queen takes and then freeze The
Rook
so like I freeze
this area
and then I play Queen takes night check
because his oh man it's in check so I'm
also gonna win the Rook unless he
freezes my queen also which is probably
what he should do
he should probably freeze my queen
because then his freeze will expire
first and he will win my queen that was
not very smart
I was not very smart
but he didn't see it so now I take his
role calls you take in that area no I'm
now I'm totally winning I think
he does have both of his freezes left
either so or no he's used one of them he
has both of his jumpers left
okay he resigns well yeah I'm totally
winning here
[Music]